ALTAN ACIKGOZ: BiTaksi
is a mobile application
that is connecting taxi
drivers with customers.
We have more than
one million customers
in Istanbul and Ankara.
And also we have taxi
drivers, more than 10,000.
HALID OZSOY: We receive
a feedback from our,
one of our visually
impaired client.
And they blogged about it.
And then we understand that
the challenges for that people
to hail a taxi.
BiTaksi is using Android's
TalkBack feature.
And we improved our service
by using that feature,
and support visually
impaired people
to hail taxis on the street.
By TalkBack option, they
can know the driver that's
coming to them, what is the
plate, how far is the driver,
and when the driver comes,
the driver helps them also.
Because they know that their
client is visually impaired.
ALTAN ACIKGOZ: We
started with cash,
and then one year later, we
added credit card payment.
After some time, we added three
more mobile payment systems
inside of the application.
These are [? Tuksum ?]
Mobile payment,
Paypal and [? PayCom ?] Express.
We will accept the [INAUDIBLE]
payments in the next month.
And this will be the
first application
that can accept contact-less
card by using NFC in Turkey.